dirty talk why do women why do women
love it sterling why don't you start
with that since well you know you're an
industry expert as an adult female star
yeah the the this is the biggest sexual
organ
rich this thing means
right that people you know people talk
about when they want to get better
better in the bedroom they talk about
like oh where's the g-spot where do i
how do i stimulate the clitoris properly
how do i get it orgasm through
penetration and it's like okay these are
you can learn all these things but also
understand that this is what kind of
drives a lot of it this is something you
can tap into
which is going to really
ratchet up and dial up
her arousal levels and her emotional
experience in the even before the
bedroom or during foreplay or during the
act of sex itself
how much of it is mental game you know
would you say
in terms of like the whole act of sex
well well well setting up to getting to
intimacy like how much mental game is
there involved you know is it a lot is
it a little bit
i mean setting up to intimacy it's basic
it's it's a large part of it and because
we talk about like being
holding frame
being perceived as high value right
these are all like what i look at it as
like okay how can you like adjust her
perceptions of reality and how can you
the guy who can like control her
emotions
in in any way right especially before
they've actually had sex and before like
this helps you meet up with a girl for
example like if you can
somehow subtly like
manipulate i don't like using the word
manipulate manipulation some people
think it's a dirty word i don't think
it's a dirty word i use i use the words
like manipulation and persuasive we can
call it influence right yeah okay
influence phil yeah if you could
influence her emotions
prior to meeting up she's going to want
to meet up with you more it's going to
make her more likely to want to meet up
with you and
that is what
can give you a lot of value in her eyes
because most dudes are boring as hell i
don't swear on your channel i remember
your your channel is kind of like pga so
most most dudes are way too freaking
boring yeah
either just
chatting in real life or texting or the
two they're very basic they're very
basic like i find you know with a lot of
women that they'll they'll uh they'll
often complain about how
basic the conversations are that they
have with guys like they don't know how
to stimulate them you know before the
actual meetup
it's a it's a little bit of a lack of
creativity a little bit of lack of
imagination and if you can tap into that
imagination of those if you can tap into
like
being mysterious for example is a
fantastic way can you give us an example
of like
hamster will ring well it's like one of
the things i actually actually give this
as an example
so in the in this this video course i'm
dropping
i not only do i talk about like dirty
talk i also talk about a bunch of
different stuff you can do
verbally
prior to meeting up with her and when
you meet up with her on the date that
can lead toward that are more likely to
lead you towards sex
one of the things i talk i talk a lot
about voice notes and the parent voice
notes in this course yes i give you an
exact
example
the base notes are very powerful
let's talk about that so
voice no especially on instagram
especially on this my personal the way i
the way i play it is like i match on a
dating app and then i get the instagram
i move to my instagram because my
instagram is
structured very well it's structured
deliberately to like make a woman go
damn
this guy that guy's an interesting man
yeah i want to see him she's like what's
he about but
when you send a woman a voice note on it
on instagram
here's what happens
when you look through your instagram dms
you can see the first line of text
without even opening it right when you
just scroll through your d i mean you
know this because you have you get a lot
of
you know dms
i haven't i haven't seen a voice note do
me a favor just grab your phone and send
me a quick voice note just so i can see
the difference in my dms
because this will be an interesting
experience because most of my dms men
should mention in a story mentioned in
story sense since then i'm sending you
the voice rich all right let's see what
you got
and there it is sterling cooper sent a
voice message whereas everything else is
sent
uh
mentioned in a story sent and text
sending a voice message is different
because you can't read the preview you
actually have to click it and open and
listen to it
bingo and that's what i mean by being
mysterious that is a subtle bit of
mystery it's curio it's tapping into
that curiosity of hers right she's like
i can read what this guy said simply
message simply message i love you you're
my queen blah blah
voice voice note what's this guy said
click and here's the even better part if
you're in the message requests section
yeah
she has to click it
it says the voice note she has to accept
it to listen to it to play it so then
you know then you're in her inbox you're
no longer in the dm request section now
you're in her inbox
and then she's missing she's listening
to the message she's like and most guys
don't have the balls to send a voice
note
they really don't it's not it's a more
of a bold move right now now some guys
might argue well sterling you have an
advantage you have a you know charming
australian accent that is true
so what would you so what would you say
to those guys that that have the average
run-of-the-mill from la miami new york
toronto sort of accent well first of all
i'd say you're absolutely right i have a
fantastic and very charming voice
uh
second of all i'd say
it doesn't that's okay that is if you
are in a different country or something
even if you're in a different state with
a like a texan accent in like new york
or something right even a slightly
different accent can can be an advantage
so yeah it is an advantage
but
you don't it doesn't mean you shouldn't
do this
you know because there's so much more
you can convey through voice
then you can convey through text you can
convey inflection you can i can say if i
i could say something in text and she
could completely misinterpret it as me
either being too needy or too or maybe
being a bit aggressive or maybe being a
bit insulting but if i send that as a
voice note with a cheeky inflection in
my voice she gets that i'm [ __ ]
around she gets that i'm having a joke
right and she's like this guy
this guy's got a sense of humor this
guy's kind of cocky this guy's kind of
funny this guy's got a bit of swagger to
him and you're demonstrating so much
more about your personality
than you can via text
and yeah and you stand out because i
mean she gets loads and loads of texts
and dms and it's all very vanilla like
one of the things that i used to do is
uh and i you know you've got to use what
you have to your advantage like sterling
has a
cheeky interesting australian accent you
know for me i sound like everybody else
in toronto but what i would do is i'd
often make the call
in my car while i was driving and all my
cars sound amazing they don't sound
boring or like priuses they sound
awesome so i'd make the call while i was
driving give it a little bit of you know
like while you're going
message you know with a little bit of an
instruction can you know you can be
cheeky sometimes dirty if it's necessary
but nobody does that most people will
not do that but but the voice note
strategy that you're talking about there
on instagram is quite a bit better
because not everybody checks voicemails
anymore people check text messages very
quickly and they check their dms very
quickly quickly but like you illustrated
just there and now and you guys are
going to try this now just see what it
looks like you know you can try it with
friends if you have to but send a voice
note just see how that pops see how that
stands out and you can do it and you can
do it like if you're texting with a girl
as well you can do it like like iphone x
yeah iphone to iphone you can um you can
literally record i don't think you can
know that you can do it from iphone to
samsung but you can definitely go from
iphone to iphone without i know you can
do it on whatsapp can't you oh and you
can definitely do it on whatsapp if you
have whatsapp yeah um i'm pretty sure i
can do voice messages on samsung i do
have yeah i do have a voice message icon
on it it's not unique to
android so it works on uh iphone two
there you go
but again it's it's it's you just play
this like anything you can do to like
stand out and play to your strengths is
is so gonna separate you from the rest
of the crowd
you know what i got to show you guys
this video that um
i uploaded to uh twitter earlier it came
off tick tock but it was this girl that
was bragging here let me show it up on
the screen uh share oh you might have
seen this today this was on your twitter
feed wasn't it yeah you might have seen
this today let me uh chrome tap share
audio twitter
uh let's see here okay so here she is
and let me just turn up some volume here
okay hang on a second hang on hang on
queen number 79. i'll get [ __ ]
well i mean you got to hear her go go
off on this because it's just too funny
all right this is going to play for me
come on stream here
how good does my apartment look by the
way look at this [ __ ] it looks look at
this [ __ ] guys it looks great it really
does look great um
okay here we go
i have proof that if you wanted to he
would i don't even know this guy this
guy has been sending me good night queen
every single night since may every
single night night queen unite queen i'm
really attached to it now sometimes if i
don't get a good night queen it like
hurts my feelings sometimes i say good
night back sometimes united queen can i
queen but this has lasted longer than
some of my relationships i feel like
everyone just this is
this is this is literally the strategy
that a lot of guys use
like this is not unique like this is not
like an oddball or an outlier this is
this is a lot more common than what a
lot of guys understand right yeah so
you know being able to stand out from
that nonsense as a guy that has a
confident strong masculine voice and if
you have a great strong deep voice use
it right i mean definitely definitely
use it uh i used to have um
except this girl that called me the
radio voice she just call me on the
phone i'm like i don't want to talk on
the phone like i'm not sitting here on
the phone so you can listen to my voice
right but it's really powerful to use a
voice message like that's the point that
i'm trying to convey so what you're
talking about absolutely works i
co-signed that
you